ja die die FDP führt zurzeit ein
Italowestern auf der hieß mal vielleicht
erinnern sich der andere noch daran
Leichen Pflastern seinen Weg heute heißt
das Klatschen Pflastern ihren Weg und
die Rede ist leider von der FDP sie hat
40% ihrer Wähler Niedersachsen verloren
40 % ist aus dem Landtag geflogen und es
war noch schlimmer 50% ihrer Wähler hat
sie verloren Schleswig-Holstein und das
konnte sie noch toppen in mir nieder
Nordrhein-Westfalen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen hat sie 60% ihrer
Wähler innerhalb von vier Jahren
verloren die FDP befindet sich auf der
Intensivstation in einer
existenzbedrohenden Lage sie redet sich
das schön mit einer staatspolitischen
Verantwortung die sie angeblich
übernehmen müssen ja das muss sie auch
sie muss aber schauen dass sie sich als
Liberale Spielerin nicht ganz aus dem
Spiel nimmt das wäre eigentlich ganz
einfach was ist denn liberal mehr
Freiheit statt Bevormundung mehr
Selbstverantwortung statt
Rundumversorgung Staats Skepsis statt
überborden des staatsvertrauen
Chancengerechtigkeit statt Geschlechter
Gleichstellung all diese Punkte
allerdings werden in der die Koalition
von der FDP gefordert zwar aber nicht
verwirklicht sie werden auf dem Altar
der koalitionsrestaurant zum Opfer
dargebracht wenn die FDP morgen noch
überleben will und wir brauchen eine
starke liberale Kraft eine Kraft die auf
Freiheit setzt statt auf Bevormundung
dann sollte sie die Koalition verlassen
solange es sie die FDP noch gibt jetzt
einmal ganz konkret die FDP soll also
die Koalition verlassen
Moment aber ohne die FDP weil
Deutschland noch viel schlimmer dran
also die FDP sagt ja immer bedankt euch
bei uns weil ohne uns wer ist ganz
schlimm natürlich aus einer gewissen
Perspektive richtig wenn vielleicht noch
höhere Steuern wenn eine noch
schlechtere unvernünftigere
corona-politik ohne Beteiligung der FDP
gleichwohl hat die FDP das Versprechen
gebrochen Anfang dieses Jahres würden
alle corona-maßnahmen Auslaufen nein sie
laufen nicht aus sie werden sogar
verschärft die Schuldenbremse steht auf
einmal zur Diskussion es ist die Rede
von einer EU-weiten schuldenhaftung also
vom vom Verband der schwäbischen
Hausfrau und die Rumpelkammer sozusagen
und die FDP muss einfach schauen dass
sie ihre Klientel nicht dermaßen
verspielt dass sie jede Gestaltungskraft
aufgibt und das wäre ja mal schade eine
Partei die sagt wählt uns damit wir das
schlimmere verhindern ist letzten Endes
vielleicht mit Schuld dass das Schlimme
passiert
geh nicht erst seit der corona-krise
wünscht man sich eine Expertenregierung
fast schon fühlen sie sich dennoch gut
regiert vor allem nach Herr kistlers
Ausführungen also mit der
Expertenregierung bin ich vorsichtig es
gibt ja bei den Philosophen mal dieses
dieses Bild der philosophenkönige die
die regieren sollten das war schon eine
schlechte Idee damals aber auch heute
bin ich nicht sicher ob man wenn man
Experten als Wissenschaftler versteht
und noch mal wirklich sagen würde nie
wissenschaftler sollten regieren da bin
ich gerade seit der coronakrise sehr
vorsichtig
aber ich stimme Kiste also da vollkommen
zu ich glaube die die FDP macht einen
wesentlichen Fehler zu glauben
dass sie sozusagen ganz viele Positionen
in der Bevölkerung in sich vereinen muss
wie eine Partei die 30 Prozent holen
will oder oder wird das wird sie nicht
haben sondern sie müssen die Politik
machen für diese gewählt worden sind von
etwa 10 bis 15% der Bevölkerung
stattdessen ja linke
gesellschaftsprojekte eines nach dem
anderen durch wir leisten uns den Luxus
einer diskrimin diskriminierungsbereiten
ident die diskriminierungsbeauftragten
Namen Frau attermann also wir haben ein
Mikromanagement in kleinste Vorgänge
hinein der Gesellschaft der Stadt wird
übergriffiger es soll Menschen verboten
werden Menschen nach dem
Geschlechterwechsel noch mit dem alten
Namen anzureden etc pp dass die Linke
Projekte für die man aus linker Sicht
kämpfen kann aber es gibt irgendwo auch
die rote Linie und ich habe den Eindruck
dass momentan die rote Linie der FDP an
zu elastisches Band ist ein spannenden
Punkt gebracht dass die FDP ja eh keine
Volkspartei ist noch nicht sein wird
sondern eine Klientelpolitik macht und
dafür auch gewählt wird das Spannende
ist ja in Niedersachsen dass die Grünen
ja sogar Gewinne noch einfahren konnten
zusätzliche die Grünen sind aber ja auch
sehr von ihrer kernwählerschaft Weg
nehmen wir mal die Abkehr vom Pazifismus
nehmen wir das mit den Atomkraftwerken
kann man nicht eigentlich fast schon
sagen dass die Grünen Wähler einfach zu
blöd sind zu merken dass sie verarscht
werden und die FDP Wähler aber leider zu
klug sind um es nicht zu merken oder ist
es zu drastisch also sie haben das jetzt
gesagt vielleicht kann man das Frage
extra formul also da über die Klugheit
oder nicht in dieser Wähler will ich
mich nicht äußern aber ich glaube in der
Tat das ist das da was dran ist wir die
Parteien müssen erkennen wofür sie
stehen wofür sie gewählt wurden auch in
besonderen Situationen wir brauchen
einen Liberalismus ich meine der
Liberalismus sind wir ein bisschen in
die Geschichte sehen hat es in
Deutschland immer schwer gehabt und es
gab auch Phasen in denen er sich völlig
neu aufstellen musste und es kann
durchaus sein dass wir wieder in einer
solchen Phase sind dass wir
möglicherweise dort eine andere
Strukturierung dieses Liberalen Angebots
in der Politik brauchen ich glaube das
ist durchaus so weit ist aber das müssen
das muss sich jetzt dann auch zeigen als
Philosoph warum hat es der Liberalismus
so schwer in unserem Land
ja das ist eine das ist eine wirklich
gute Frage
sind die Deutschen von sich aus in
liberaler manche würden das vielleicht
so sagen die Deutschen sind sind zu
konservativ oder auch zu zu
autoritätsgläubig ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob das stimmt also ob das so
pauschalen nur stimmt es gibt sicherlich
Aspekte davon und wir haben in
Deutschland zwei Diktaturen erlebt aber
ich glaube nicht dass das der einzige
Grund ist sondern ich glaube manchmal
auch dass die Angebote die gemacht
werden in der seitens der Politik nicht
gut genug es war ich finde es nach wie
vor eine Folge des überbordnen
Sozialstaats wir eben unser Bismarck
begonnen hat dass man sich dran gewöhnt
hat in Deutschland mittlerweile im
dritten Jahrhundert schon wenn ich ins
19 zurück schaue der Start ist letzten
Endes der große Ernährer und er darf
deshalb auch der sein der sagen wo ich
zu denken habe das ist ein ein großes
großes Problem dass man das kurzschließt
die Ernährung Funktion die eigentlich
nur in Sicherheitsnetz sein sollte mit
der Kompetenz sie haben den Staat
zuspricht über richtiges und falsches
Denken zu urteilen es ging schon bei
einfach zusammen einerseits
Sozialgesetzgebung andererseits Kampf
gegen Katholiken und gegen Proletarier
er wird man sicherheitspolitisch werden
neu waren jetzt ein großes Risiko
Neuwahlen ja wenn die Ampel kollabiert
oder die FDP sagt wir sind raus dann
wird der Neuwahlen geben also in dieses
auf dieses Thema möchte ich mich gar
nicht einlassen ich glaube alle in der
deutschen Politik haben erkannt dass
äußere Sicherheit mit innerer Sicherheit
viel stärker verbunden als früher eine
Grund ein Grundbedürfnis ist das
befriedigt werden muss und dass wir 30
Jahre lang uns in der Sicherheit gewiegt
haben dass wir nur von Freunden umgeben
sind ohne zu beachten dass unsere
Freunde nicht von Freunden umgeben sind
den Balken haben wir gesagt nur werdet
man nicht hier hysterisch wegen Russland
die polnische Kritik an Nord Stream 2
und der Abhängigkeit von Russland haben
wir nicht erkennen wollen also ich
glaube jedwede
Konstellation wird in der
Sicherheitspolitik ähnlich handeln
müssen wie das jetzt
erkannt worden ist und
ob man dann vielleicht die Zögerlichkeit
in der Unterstützung der Ukraine in
anderen Konstellationen anders sehen
würde das ist teilweise auch eine Frage
der handelnden Person eine Zahl 63
Prozent der Deutschen sagen diese
Parteien bringen uns nicht durch die
Krise es sei denn alarmierendes Signal
auch sicherheitspolitisch wenn wir auf
Deutschland blicken und nicht
außenpolitisch blicken
ich bin ja im nebenfachhaus Soziologe
gewesen ich glaube nur der Statistik die
ich selber gefälscht habe um das alte
Hormon noch einmal zu bemühen und da
kommt es immer darauf an wie die Frage
gestellt wird und bringt uns durch die
Krise die Krise hat viele Seiten und
mein Metier ist hier mehr die
Sicherheitspolitik dazu sage ich auch
gerne noch acht innere Sicherheit innere
Sicherheit gehört dazu und gerade für
eine rechtsstaatspartei wie die FDP
müsste eigentlich die innere Sicherheit
ein starkes Feld sein und wenn man sich
in Koalitionsvertrag anschaut kommt
innere Sicherheit eigentlich unter
ferner liefen nur vor das heißt auch da
sehe ich eine Bringschuld der FDP die
sie gemeinsam mit eigentlich auch an
Sicherheit interessierten Kräften
innerhalb der SPD viel stärker nach
vorne bringen könnte stattdessen wird
also viel getan und die Delegation
unserer staatlichen Institution
voranzutreiben also Bundeswehr Polizei
werden teilweise teilweise unter
Generalverdacht gestellt und da bräuchte
es auch eine starke selbstbewusste
Verfassungstreue rechtsstaatspartei wie
die FDP die sagen auf dem Boot unseres
Grundgesetzes schützen wir alle die sich
zu ihm bekennen Herr spiegelsberger sie
auch als Bürger gefragt wie empfinden
Sie denn die Lage in unserem Land
dramatisch würde ich ganz einfach mal
sagen also was von der Politik in die
letzten Jahre eigentlich gekommen ist
das heißt mit der corona-krise mit dem
Maßnahmen oder auch jetzt wie gesagt ich
kann solche Sachen nicht verstehen dass
man überhaupt auf die Idee kommt
Atomkraftwerke jetzt abschalten zu
wollen oder dies war viel zu spät dass
mir jetzt sagt die Kohlekraftwerke
sollen weiterlaufen und danach nur für
drei Monate was machen wir im nächsten
Winter es ändert sich ja nichts so
kurzfristig und insofern muss ich sagen
was momentan in der Politik passiert ist
definitiv nicht für uns Bürger
natürlich
heute tanken zum Beispiel ich war vor
kurzem in Italien unten ich war in
Kroatien da ist der Sprit um 50 60 Cent
günstiger als bei uns in Deutschland und
ich frage mich die kaufen ja nicht
teurer ein also muss es ja irgendwo an
der Steuer oder sonstiges liegen und ich
verstehe nicht dass die Politik hier
dann nicht sagt die Firmen haben alle
ich bin seit Jahren selbstständig ich
rede mit viele Firmeninhaber die haben
alle riesen Probleme sei es
Materiallieferungen sei es natürlich
gestiegene Kosten gestiegene Löhne die
wissen gar nicht wie sie das nur
reinbringen wollen es haben viele Firmen
draußen die mittlerweile eigentlich kurz
vorm Kollaps an und im Gegensatz zum
unseren Wirtschaftsminister soll gehört
wenn der Firma nichts mehr verkauft dann
ist die Kongress